there's nothing holding me back the tear
up my reputation anyway there we are you
get the idea i do that one so i know
that one we've got exclusive interviews
and footage from the recording sessions
of the incredible lineup of stars in
sing 2. we're talking some serious music
and acting legends how many number one
hits do we got let's dive in
just imagine it a spectacular musical
number one it's hard to pick which
scarlett johansson character is our
favorite black widow or ash the coolest
porcupine around oh gosh
the actress has been doing voice over
for years seriously we're talking
decades one of her earliest underwater
princess mindy spongebob wherever you
are you better hurry recording sing two
was quite a different experience though
since they did it all during a pandemic
we recorded it in such isolation just
because she was often recording alone
didn't mean she wasn't digging the whole
process though
especially when it came to some of the
tunes she got to belt out i don't need
the demo i know the song number two yes
the bono of you two is in fact the voice
of musician clay callaway in the sing
sequel it is always a party when bono
shows up as far as personality goes he
was a pretty perfect pick for the part
some people sing for a living some
people sing to survive i am one of
the latter this was very new territory
for bono never having done an animated
feature film but he knocked it out of
the park even the director garth
jennings could see it he was just
enthusiasm from the start curiosity and
enthusiasm and equal measure i mean you
couldn't ask for more yeah we'd be
pretty jazzed if we were directing bono
too in terms of being a director knowing
that this character is going to be
voiced by bono it's as good as it gets
as for bono himself's favorite part well
let's just say he has excellent taste
and we love it too
number three it wouldn't be sing without
this fabulous singing pig i play rosita
in sing two no wonder reese came back
for such a great role witherspoon is no
stranger to movies or voice over but
performing and sing well it's literally
my dream come true but of course that
didn't come without intimidation i had
to sing prince ariana grande you too
i was so scared it was definitely worth
braving through the nerves since the
actress found one particularly special
song i got to sing an ariana grande song
and it was so fun singing break free it
just felt like there was a song in my
heart and just had to come out and it
was break free and i didn't even know
until i got to sing it it's no wonder
her performance is so good with that
kind of passion behind it made me sound
good number four this might sound crazy
what we're about to say but yes that was
pharrell williams you heard voicing
alfonso and sing too it's such an
incredible cast already and then to add
bono and pharrell it's like dreams come
true yeah no kidding
what's even cooler is the fact that the
singer has never had a major film role
before this was a solid first choice for
sure fingers crossed we get more
pharrell as animated animals soon it's
just testament to the way the audience
is connected with the first movie that
musicians of that caliber want to come
and be a part of it it's super super
exciting and quite surreal number five
couldn't resist coming back for more
seeing fun i was falling in love
kelly isn't usually on a set and when
she is in a recording booth she's
typically singing as herself singing is
it's everything but this time her voice
gave life to mina again i completely
forgot that there was a camera on me
because you just get so into the scene
and it's the moment recording during the
pandemic meant a lot of time was spent
in that booth alone mr moon i'm not so
good in small space lucky for kelly she
got to start playing around with her
part a bit early i was like you know i
have a studio like i didn't want to like
have to wait super long so i just kind
of offered it i was like i could record
stuff if you guys want oh and the vibes
super chill it was cool just being at
home you know like in my sweats even
when we would go in to record parts in
in their studio it was just like
relaxing the dream cast dream songs
what's not to love i've gotten to sing
all these iconic incredible songs so
i've never once been like huh i don't
know about this one let's maybe try this
song step together drop number six
usually his face is on screen but who
could resist the chance to play the
buster moon again buster's the most
active koala that i've that probably
there is on the planet in the universe
voice acting can be a dream for an actor
wanting to play around with their
performance that's one of the great
things you don't even have to think
about what you're wearing so i don't
know what the hell i was wearing there's
nothing self-conscious about it try and
screw up you can't for the sing sequel
the buster moon actor got to stay close
to home to record from my studio in
austin texas wait in his own house yeah
nice at my office that work from home
life came with an extra special perk the
movie became a family affair okay guys
just like we rehearsed my daughter vida
got a couple lines he'll win this movie
honestly her role might be better than
her dad's she plays a piglet who's scuba
diving in chocolate either way our
buster moon brought pretty special
moments to life we're gonna put the show
on whether crystal likes it or not but
first
we're gonna jump out that window
dream big dreams that's what i always
said right number seven is that a fierce
singing grey arctic wolf well sort of
it's also the voice of halsey shining
bright like a diamond paulie has the
most amazing number it is her first
major acting role but we wouldn't be
surprised if there were more after this
she's already very at home inside that
recording booth and guess what this girl
is on fire
number eight who's that impeccably
dressed wolf introducing mr crystal aka
bobby cannavale the actor has spent
plenty of time in front of the cameras
and even in the recording booth for the
animated series big mouth but joining
the sing squad well this is exactly the
kind of big idea i'm talking about
number nine who else could play this
feisty pig so perfectly and i'm very
happy to be back doing sing since the
first sing movie crawl has been busy
with other projects
yeah
big time baby including voicing multiple
characters including nick birch in big
mouth with his co-star bobby but busy as
his schedule is nothing was going to
stop him from coming back it's a joy to
voice him while a lot of the other
actors in sync 2 are experienced singers
i like singing although i'm not very
good at it we'd have to disagree there
though we dig winter singing all the way
i leave my singing to the professional
singing which is probably the wrong way
to do it but it's how it's unfolded nah
we think winter said it best ah i think
we pretty much nailed it got the robot
activating piggy power
number ten the gorilla with the voice of
a god if you could just give me some
dance lessons you would literally be
saving my life we've got taran eagerton
coming in hot as the fabulous johnny
come with me in rehearsal safely
eagerton has an impressive resume
including the movie musical rocket man
where we got a taste of the voice we'd
hear sounding just as sweet except
coming from an animated gorilla to
re-enter this world and revisit such a
lovely
um
character
you know is a dream come true working
with director garth jennings was a solid
part of what made the experience so
special you walk into one of those
recording sessions it begins with garth
explaining everything he's been up to
since the last time i was there and then
contextualizing whatever bit of the
story we're dealing with another vital
part of this all-star team
number eleven has there ever been a more
fabulous yak i'm gonna win a ton of
awards for this we think not fingers
crossed andre brings comedy gold to sync
too unsurprising since he spends so much
time recording voices for animated
series like disenchantment and archer
he's new to the sing crew but he
definitely left his mark number 12. last
but certainly not least writer director
and actor in sing two the one and only
garth jennings i feel like he loves to
act out the characters for you it's his
movie and he can do what he wants to and
who wouldn't want to jump at the chance
to portray this fiery iguana i love miss
crawley jennings was extremely busy on
this project and the first sing movie
which happened to be the very first time
he directed a live action animated film
but jumping into the booth well it just
made the experience that much better she
is sort of ridiculous and delightful in
equal measure and just so much fun to
play it is such a joy to just stand
behind a microphone and try and be miss
crawley
make your family proud
it's time to meet the madrigal family
and more many of the performers dove
into acting for the very first time with
this movie and tons of them recorded in
isolation from all over the world we're
checking out 12 of the performers behind
the voices of encanto
one of the amazing madrigals i'm the
voice of mirabelle from walt disney
animation studios in canton stephanie
beatrice blows her performance out of
the water doing her colombian father
proud i'm part of the amazing madrigal
the actress has been on a roll from
playing rosa diaz in brooklyn nine-nine
to countless other projects she's been
taking on including plenty of time in
the booth recording voices for bob's
burgers she did have her fair share of
flubs in the booth for this one though
let's do it again please thank you a
lifelong lover of disney taking on this
role was a literal dream come true
i will save the miracle
now she can help inspire other people to
believe that anything is possible i'm
sure there's behind the scenes footage
to show how much fun i was having
definitely yes
even though they worked together from a
distance stephanie's performance still
got lin-manuel miranda right in the
feels i don't know i hope i did it
justice oh no worries about that anyone
that sees the movie knows that she
absolutely did i found this last vision
the family's in trouble the magic is
dying the house is breaking we skipped
his fading and i think it's all because
of
me
make way abuela is coming through disney
is an american company but that didn't
mean maria cecilia botero had to leave
colombia to do one of their movies with
the pandemic happening over the course
of recording the actress stayed in her
home country working with the creative
team on zoom
with a
blessed eat with her
[Music]
they may never have shared the room
together but that didn't stop potero
from having an amazing collaboration
with the team even when she thought she
was flubbing she was nailing it i'm
talking too fast
no that sounds great
we know we don't talk about bruno but
we gotta talk about bruno john leguizamo
is one of the busiest actors around but
a packed schedule wasn't gonna stop him
from making room for encanto after all i
made the sparkle his charm is like no
other the performance that comes through
his character on screen really makes an
impact and from the looks of the booth
footage he didn't hold back a thing to
make the candle break you have to
embrace your embrace
any chance of some bruno shorts coming
at us in the future disney hey if you
save the encounter come visit need a
sweet voice encanto has you covered
valderama is no stranger to voice over
or to disney he played gaxton and onward
and is the manny of handy manny you must
be very excited he also happens to have
been the face behind fez in that 70s
show this role meant the world to him
especially because his own mother is
colombian
this part was all heart she's right i'm
more
on screen or behind the mic this actress
works it from jane the virgin to
countless spanish television shows and
movies the colombian actress has made
waves in the industry and really made
her mark in the disney world as julieta
what i think
is that today was very hard for you
celebrating the premiere was super
special since she was one of the many
actors who recorded from their homes
never actually meeting everyone in
person
so so happy because it's the first time
that we meet we didn't really
get to know each other
number six
she goes by dolores in encanto but she
is also known as the reggaeton princess
she didn't get one while she's a
successful singer this is her first time
diving into the acting business i just
felt like a tiger like i seized the
moment luckily it happened because when
she first sent in her audition tape it
went straight to spam the next morning
we had we hadn't heard back and i was
like okay maybe we should write
something and then everything was sorted
but then tragedy struck when arasa found
herself unable to move struggling with
some side effects from having covid19
but then she got word that disney wanted
her to play dolores
and the day she finally got to get to
work well there was no holding back i
was like all right like give it to me
and then i just let it rip in one take
and he was like we're done and i was
like yes
we have a feeling this won't be her last
voiceover roll
that's like the cherry on top of a dream
hair toss check her nails isabella's
ready from jane the virgin to orange is
the new black guerrero never fails to
show just how wide her range is she was
embodying every single part of isabella
while recording her dialogue at the
booth when she got her chance to sing
well she was just a little excited about
it been like waking up with the song and
going to sleep with it even when she
wasn't performing the songs she just
couldn't stay away from bringing those
musical vibes making the movie that much
better
[Music]
i don't know if you wanted me to sing
one of the highlights for the american
colombian actress was of course getting
to work with lin-manuel miranda even if
it was via screen always make those
questions into questions they didn't
need to be together to bring the magic
i just made something unexpected
number eight
she's feisty and she's fierce she's
luisa with the super strength encanto
marked the cuban american actress's very
first voiceover role while she recorded
the whole thing remotely during the
pandemic she did get to spend some time
in person with the creative team off the
bat i actually had the incredible
opportunity to audition in person in la
right before the pandemic hit which was
pretty wild her performance made louisa
a total standout in the movie especially
that glorious song of hers here's hoping
we'll be hearing a lot more about this
fab actress soon sweet
thank you all that was good
if you've ever been to colombia you've
probably heard about this guy not just
felix of the madrigals but moro castillo
as well since he's an extremely
successful and popular singer and actor
and trombonist talk about being
multi-talented he brought all the good
vibes to the booth
it was a celebration during the making
and the launch especially after spending
a very long time recording everything to
get it just right uh we are working from
uh
for like
a year maybe maybe a year
make way we've got a star coming through
young as he may look juan castano has
already been working for over a decade
making a name for himself on screen and
hit shows like tales of the city and
what if he really made his first voice
overall count in encanto stealing every
scene he's in and very obviously having
a blast in that booth as gift ceremony
was a bummer
what fun is bringing the 60th animated
disney movie to life without some joking
around in laughter hey i'll play casita
yellow card yellow card need a charmer
look no further maluma shot to fame as a
singer with that oh so sweet voice of
his and the way he feels about the music
of his country well it just makes us
adore him even more colombian music is
special because we do it with our heart
you know we do it with love considering
how much fun he had and how much magic
he brings to the movie we wouldn't be
surprised if he voices some more
characters soon
she's a legend no big deal rose portillo
has been acting since the 1970s
starring in countless tv shows and films
over the years she gained a whole new
group of fans from her performance as
senora gusman that there weren't
problems with the monthly god magic
can you still hear him no just you
which luca actor recorded most of the
film from their mom's closet
we see the final product but behind the
scenes recording remotely during a
pandemic looks very very different than
normal
this was actually the first time some of
these actors had ever done voice work
today we're checking out the performers
behind the voices that brought us disney
pixar's luca
i know your problem you got a bruno in
your head a bruno jacob trombley is only
14 years old but already a total pro in
the film world
he's done roles in live action movies
like room and wonder
however voice work is a very different
experience and discipline
for trombley it wasn't too much of an
issue anyway since he has years of
experience doing it he's been the voice
of pete for the past few years in pete
and the cat and of course he will also
be voicing flounder in the upcoming
live-action remake of the little mermaid
his animated voice really brings this
hilarious moment to life
[Music]
seeing emma berman performing behind the
scenes makes it so hard to believe that
she's still pretty new to the business
this is actually her first major project
are you in town for the race
while the trio may just be meeting it
feels like they're already at the
beginning of a great adventure and
friendship together emma berman's
sweetness comes through on the screen
and behind the scenes which is extra
impressive considering she's not acting
opposite anyone
jack dylan grazer has done plenty of
movies and tv shows already i've been
doing this forever but it's still early
days for grazer when it comes to voice
over performance
it's it's it's been so much fun it's
really hard it really has so for him it
was a big adjustment since he couldn't
actually look at the people he was
acting opposite however he really got
into it and as we can see was definitely
able to get his point across luca it's
simple just don't listen to stupid bruno
this pep talk works
fortunately it wasn't as drastic for
trombley himself as it happened behind
the scenes
but he managed to portray the panic
extremely well he's dead i killed him
the worry that he'd lost his best friend
comes through perfectly in his voice
here
this kind of acting should be helpful
when he's taking on flounder who goes
through plenty of panic of his own
alberto communicating the fact that he's
a sea monster could definitely be tricky
but somehow newcomer grazer does a spot
on job it's fine i'm not human what's
even more impressive about this
performance is that it was done out of
his mom's closet very very very far from
this quaint italian town however grazer
had actually just been in italy only two
months before he discovered he'd gotten
the part filming another project
so luckily everything in his life felt
pretty in sync and he could feel those
italian vibes
wait it's called phantom tail he'll get
used to it watching berman behind the
scenes is so exciting because she's so
animated while she's performing we can
see how it emanates what her character
does on screen perfectly julia is an
optimistic girl but even she has her
doubts about the abilities of these sea
monsters and understandably so you can't
swim you can barely ride a bike saturn
disaster we wouldn't be a fan of
disastrous either how alberto learned to
walk so well we're not entirely sure but
he seems pretty well-versed when it
comes to it luca does have a great and
enthusiastic teacher even though his
instructions might not be the most
helpful sometimes walking is just like
swimming but with no fins or tail and
also there's no water the chemistry
between alberto and luca is really
special which is extra impressive since
the actors haven't actually met in
person that's right they developed this
beautiful on-screen friendship and all
without ever actually speaking face to
face
it was like oh wow emma berman makes for
a very good trainer maybe even better
than alberto there was no hesitancy in
getting them into shape the boys are
definitely being well prepared by her as
she's clearly thought of everything can
you dodge obstacles what if an old lady
crosses your path we would just love to
see berman and her co-stars performing
the scene live as well
learning how to ride a bike is a pretty
amazing feeling for anyone but
especially for a sea monster who let's
remember also just learned how to walk
trombley's enthusiasm radiates behind
the scenes julia said look up and then
all of a sudden i was writing it we can
see that he and luca are very similarly
animated in their performance the town
will cheer our names erkola's life will
be ruined once julia has her mind set on
something there is no turning back we
can feel just how excited not only julia
is but berman the actress herself it was
definitely really really good
the enthusiasm about working with her
new friends and feeling re-inspired
really comes through in this scene they
definitely sound like winners
that's why we gotta win one of the
sweetest moments in the whole movie is
definitely when luca describes the
dreams of his adventures with alberto
around the world
every day mina alberto are gonna ride
someplace new it's a touching and tender
moment that translates beautifully to
the screen
trombley's presence comes through behind
the mic and we can hear every single
sweet note
and every night we'll sleep under the
fish
julia is one of the most organized and
determined kids that we've ever seen
i actually relate to her in some ways
considering her positivity and how well
she motivates the team it seems like
their chances are pretty good
we have one week to train bronte apostle
they won the enthusiasm award for sure
we love seeing berman's physicality
behind the mic she embodies the
character of julia perfectly
too much my mom says sometimes i'm too
much no way not for me jim gaffigan is
usually a stand-up comedian so it makes
sense why his performance is so strong
and his comedic timing so on point all
right young man
you're not fooling anyone his sneak
attack on this unexpecting italian child
brings a hilarious moment to the movie
one that gaffigan portrays perfectly
it's time for us to go home his energy
behind the mic really amps the scene up
this moment under the fish or stars
depending on if you're a human or a sea
monster is a pretty magical moment no
matter how you look at it
it's my favorite berman's performance is
genuine and full of sweetness
we can really understand how luca would
become so excited by the world and all
of its wonders seeing it through julia's
eyes this is how machines fly see and
they're big towns called city so cool
right when she's on land luca's mom
daniella does not hold back even her
husband lorenzo is a bit nervous by her
boldness
gaffigan's hesitant performance is very
obvious behind the mic as well honey no
i
i don't it's amazing that his chemistry
with maya rudolph was so strong even
though they didn't get to act with each
other directly we look horrifying ugh
gross and as long as we have the blue
dust we'll never run out of flying dust
sometimes they're mcu superheroes and
other days they're giving voice to
amazing animated characters today we're
taking a look at the varied animated
characters in some of our favorite
movies and tv shows that are performed
by marvel actors which performer wrote
to the production team asking to be part
of their show which grinch line was
improvised by benedict cumberbatch
what in the world is happening
the film onward has not one but two
marvel stars lending their voices to
bring this pair of brothers to life who
are you
we're the avengers man during press for
the movie chris pratt said that it was
one of the most emotional films he'd
ever experienced working on in his
career in part because of his personal
connection to the material no i have
three remember his beard was scratchy
had a goofy laugh and he used to play
drums on his feet pratt said that the
brotherly relationship he portrays with
holland feels similar to his
relationship with his actual brother for
holland it was a pretty special
experience as well tapping into any
brain just let me go explaining that
this film has made me love my dad even
more after watching this wonderful film
we'll call their loved ones and tell
them how much they love them and
appreciate them ryan reynolds was
fascinated when he first saw the fully
rendered version of pikachu because of
just how skilled the work of the
animators was it was a bit of a shock to
see just how real the pikachu felt and
how well the characters suited the voice
and of course vice versa harry faked his
own death or
somebody else faked harry's death one of
the reasons reynolds was excited about
being part of pokemon detective pikachu
was because it's a movie he knew he
could share with his children since it
was slated to be such a family film i
was excited to do a film that my kids
would love for me that's a big one it
makes sense since so many of his past
projects definitely weren't what he'd
want to show to his young kids at the
time a while before she took to the
screen as black widow johansson spent
some time with spongebob squarepants the
actress was just 19 years old at the
time johansson was the voice of princess
mindy here take this a mermaid living
underwater who whips out some mermaid
magic to support patrick and spongebob
in the spongebob squarepants movie
spongebob wherever you are you better
hurry filming spies in disguise was
quite the feat for the spider-man actor
super nerd which is me i always seem to
play the nerd has to um kind of step up
and help him save the day his role as
scientist walter beckett was the very
first full-length film he did voice over
for a hydrothermal explosion is about to
melt your face off while holland had
loads of interactions with his co-star
in the movie he didn't actually meet
will smith in person in the entire two
and a half years they were making the
film pretend like you're a normal person
talking to a much cooler normal person
the actors were based in different
cities while recording holland in new
york and smith in los angeles it was
only during press that they actually got
to meet the marvel actor pair got a
chance to put their spy skills to work
when they did an escape room together
spies in disguise tom holland will smith
is like it's very very funny scarlett
johansson didn't just do voice over
early on in her career she's been a
brilliant addition to multiple projects
including the live action mowgli yes
would you like to see
it was a really exciting experience for
johansen who got to reinvent the
character for this version of the story
since she played ka as a seductive
female storyteller whereas in the
cartoon kaw is a boy and more of a goofy
pal to mowgli the way khan moves in the
animation affected her vocal performance
and vice versa don't you know what you
are
i know what you are
when chris pratt heard about the lego
movie two years before it was even made
the actor was extremely excited by what
sounded like a film that would speak to
adults and children alike in a creative
way i just was blown away at the
inventiveness the creativity for the
second lego movie he took on the role of
rex dangervest and was able to bring a
different vocal quality to the screen
emmett was perkier and higher pitch wow
my own rexvest
well he got to go with a rougher sound
for dangerous voice
trust me it's ruled by an alien queen
and she'll try to brainwash your friends
andy circus was extremely impressed
while he was directing doctor strange
actor benedict cumberbatch in the mowgli
film for one he gave a very physical
performance and was actually wearing a
head-mounted camera to capture his
movements for the film part of what made
this role a stand out for the actor was
how cumberbatch brought out the layers
of personality and shared a character
who while he was a villain was also
complex in his own right you do not want
to challenge me the animated film the
pirate fairy saw none other than loki of
the mcu as captain james hook exactly we
needed a captain hiddleston not only
shares his speaking voice in the film
but his singing as well when asked about
the experience hiddleston said he had
the time of his life part of the reason
he loves voice work so much is because
of the challenge of telling a story and
only having his voice to express himself
look at that man having so much fun
being him doctor strange played another
legendary character
the grinch benedict cumberbatch would
get really into the character's
physicality while in the recording booth
to the point that he actually had to be
cautious not to ruin the quality of the
voice recording you will not see me
later and i will not be celebrating
cumberbatch had a lot of fun and even
improvised while he was in the booth the
line yeah yeah yeah have a nice life it
was made up on the spot while recording
and since it suited the role and film it
managed to be included tessa thompson
aka valkyrie had a strong connection to
the live-action film lady and the [ __ ]
i think you can be on your way now
thanks for your help in a press
interview she said it was one of the
greatest love stories ever told the
classic spaghetti kiss scene was
actually the first time that she thought
about romance when she was young the
actress has another personal connection
to the role as well she is the proud
owner of a rescue pup the actress
credited her dog counterpart as an
excellent performer and expressed the
joy that came with giving a voice to a
real animal she got to interact with
look i have been on the street maybe for
not as long as you but i have done it
when we think of black widow we don't
usually think of music but scarlett
johansson actually had a fairly solid
music career in the 2000s releasing
multiple albums and eps as well as being
part of a girl group the actress got to
show off her voice when she played ash
and sang set it all free in the film
sing when asked about working on
recording the film johansen said the
experience was so fun and free who can
ask for anything better than that
uh
you guys okay
did frozone's voice sound familiar to
you hey
that isn't going to hold them long
samuel l jackson did the voice for the
animated character in both the
incredibles and the incredibles 2.
that is freaky when it came to making
the second film jackson said it was a
relief because so many fans had been
inquiring after the first one came out
iron man himself made a cameo and family
guy only not as the avenger but instead
as lois's long-lost brother who was once
locked away in an insane asylum he's
feeding he killed twice and he's gonna
do it again robert downey jr was the one
who made the first move since he was a
big fan of the show and had wanted to be
part of it for quite a while he has to
be part of the show somehow and when the
time was right the marvel actor made one
guest appearance as patrick
pewterschmidt
the ant-man actor was the very first
person who brought to life the fiance to
susan derrick dietl in monsters vs
aliens no susan you're like really
glowing you're green
when the tv series short came around
actor nolan north took over the role for
both the first and second lego movies
none other than the mcu's maria hill aka
kobe smalders was the voice of lego
wonder woman she's off having a separate
standalone adventure the actress said it
was really fun because she felt like she
was part of a mini avengers in the lego
world
and i think you two are better together
than you are apart well i work alone
or at least not with him let's just say
he's the boss i'm the boss when the boss
baby hit theaters back in the spring of
2017 it was a huge hit with audiences
four years later fans are able to
reconnect with ted and tim templeton
he's not a baby anymore we have adult
ted the film's voice cast is stacked
with a-list stars and even some rising
ones
[Music]
today we're learning about the behind
the scenes of what went into recording
the boss baby family business
you're a baby
i repeat
you're a baby
alec baldwin is one of the most highly
recognized actors working today and he's
certainly no stranger to voice acting
outside of voicing the titular boss baby
ted templeton baldwin has lent his voice
to films like the spongebob squarepants
movie this is what a real mustache looks
like
as well as dreamworks rise of the
guardians i feel it you may also know
him from hit shows and movies like 30
rock saturday night live and the mission
impossible franchise for their
salvageable assets to the cia a majority
of the cast of boss baby family business
recorded their lines from home something
that wasn't entirely new to baldwin
comparing the recording process to how
he records his podcast despite this he
says he still had to experiment with
what apps and equipment he could use
while recording his lines baldwin uses
his signature sly charm when delivering
this line while bickering with his
on-screen brother james marsden tim i'm
going to give you the name of a doctor
roy fetterman just tell him i sent you
okay so much for brotherly love can i
talk to you in the kitchen
amy sedaris has made the rounds in
hollywood acting as well as providing
her voice to plenty of popular movies
and shows such as bojack horseman where
she voiced princess caroline this could
happen five more times but i'm ready for
that because i want this the mandalorian
and elf
like marsden sedaris is a new addition
to the cast but unlike her new co-star
she's voicing an entirely new character
tina templeton the new boss baby in
charge who just so happens to be tim's
daughter why do you need help using your
phone like baldwin sedaris started off
her voice work from home before moving
to a studio thanks to the pandemic she
expressed that the process was difficult
especially since she wasn't working off
anyone else's energy like she was used
to doing she channels the hyperactive
spirit of tina during this scene where
she introduces herself to her dad after
she caused him to faint daddy daddy
daddy can you read me daddy daddy debbie
how many fingers am i holding up in this
humorous sequence ted finds himself
having to sneak through the acorn center
for advanced childhood in order to reach
the office of mysterious and equally
nefarious dr edwin armstrong
baldwin is able to channel his inner
irritated personality during this moment
where ted falls onto a rather sticky
carpet it's like they always say if you
want something done right you have to do
it without your brother
while debriefing a babyfied ted and tim
on their mission to save babycorp tina
lets her father and uncle know who's in
charge sederis brings her signature
snark that she brought to many of her
other characters during this scene well
i'm the boss applesauce and i think you
two are better together than you are
apart talk about bossy but that doesn't
make sense for this movie
sedaris claims that tina's zodiac sign
is most definitely a virgo that claim
definitely seems to be true in this
scene featuring her revealing to tim
that she's the new boss baby yes baby
corp is more of what i call a side
hustle for me the point is i am all in
one on the templeton over the course of
the two boss baby movies alec baldwin
has been full of one-liners while
voicing the role of ted from the classic
line that cookie down cookies are for
closers to your father is a hippie
baldwin doesn't miss when going for a
laugh with these lines he gives one of
his best liners yet in this scene where
he learns dr armstrong's shocking secret
surprise surprise
what the frittata
amy sedaris's tina gives tim some brutal
honesty in this scene sedaris has
already played very business forward
characters before as seen in her role on
the netflix animated series bojack
horseman here she brings the bluntness
and straightforward nature of being a
boss baby even analyzing her own parents
it looks like cedarus may have even gone
off script while getting into character
you guys really know how to baby a baby
i mean it's incredible now that it's all
five star i say you have a lot of issues
after all the craziness that went on
during his meeting with the evil dr
armstrong ted gives the perfect response
on his way
well i think that went well it's the
kind of simple and empathetic delivery
that helps make this scene all the more
comedic amy sedaris's tina isn't always
as business forward as she presents
herself to be in this scene where ted
exclaims to his brother that he may have
finally cracked the code on the whole
parenting thing she takes a moment to
praise her father albeit in a typical
boss baby fashion gold star for you
daddy now keep it up pups things get
pretty heated in this moment between
baldwin and marsden as they argue over
whether tina can actually talk or not
what makes this scene all the more
impressive is that both of them recorded
their lines separately suck it ted i
thank your pardon you suck no no tim you
suck in one of her first lines in the
film amy sedaris channels her inner
chucky when revealing to her dad that
she can actually talk just like ted
could when he was an infant
hi daddy
okay maybe that's not the best way to
introduce yourself
is that you as dr armstrong shows ted
around his secret evil lair underneath
the acorn center baldwin's ted asks a
question that's probably on all the
audience's minds as well in this
self-aware comment um so
why bother with school
you could go public
and make millions
during this moment sat at the baby corp
headquarters ted starts to realize what
tina's plan really is and where he falls
into it he gives the same response that
we'd all probably have in this situation
wait wait wait wait wait
you want me to be a baby they don't call
it boss baby for nothing ted
but teamwork doesn't seem work
james marsden has always been able to
bring his charisma throughout his career
starring in films like sonic the
hedgehog enchanted and playing marvel
superhero cyclops in the x-men franchise
like baldwin boss baby family business
isn't marsden's first voice acting role
but he is a new addition to the cast
regardless marsden is still able to show
some fatherly warmth when delivering the
lines opposite his boss baby daughter
voiced by amy sedaris what is it this
time
kittens no
this time it's even worse where's the
kittens well he may not have had the
other actors to riff off james marsden
seemed to still be having a great time
recording his lines while recording this
fast-paced action scene where tim and
ted use a rambunctious pony to get to
the acorn center marsden was clearly
showing off a lot of energy
[Music]
i'm gonna go where navigation set
it must have been hard not to laugh at
baldwin's response
she can't talk tim
tap it around
again i want to go
she can't talk to him
the zombies are like
eating everyone who doesn't love a good
spooky animated film yes whether it be
centering around a family that's creepy
and kooky a hotel for monsters run by
dracula and his daughter or a young boy
who is transported to the land of the
remembered some of your favorite actors
and actresses have lended their voices
to these popular spine-tingling animated
flicks
this is gonna be harder than i thought
the hotel transylvania movies boast
quite the impressive ensemble of actors
but mavis voiced by selena gomez has
always stood out as a fan favorite it
may surprise you that gomez almost did
not even voice mavis and that miley
cyrus was initially cast before her
gomez has expressed just how much fun
she has being a part of the
monster-filled franchise wow i can't
believe i'm actually here
adam sandler is one of the most popular
comedic actors in the world headlining
comedy movies such as happy gilmore
murder mystery and grown-ups as well as
many others though his most popular
franchise is perhaps hotel transylvania
welcome to hotel
transylvania adam sandler voiced the
comical spin on the iconic vampire for
the first three films alongside a cast
of several of his frequent collaborators
director of the films revealed that
sandler signed on to play dracula for
his daughters as he wanted to be part of
a movie they could watch and enjoy as a
family no no no i didn't mean to startle
you my little baby
dakota fanning had been making waves
even before she was cast as the title
character and like a stop-motion
adaptation of neil gaiman's coral line
fanning at the time had already starred
in adaptations of other popular books
for young readers such as charlotte's
web and the cat in the hat fanning was
originally planning to star as coraline
in a live action film but director henry
selick ultimately changed his mind and
went the animated route while recording
her lines fanning even had to record
grunting and falling sounds for her
character along with the dialogue
coraline
coraline jones
leica's 2012 stop-motion movie film
paranorman has quite the cast of quirky
yet lovable characters including pitch
perfect star anna kendrick who voices
courtney the older sister of the title
character paranorman was kendrick's
first animated film as it debuted four
years before the release of trolls where
she voiced the lovable poppy in
paranorman kendrick was able to channel
her inner teenage girl from crushing on
boys talking on the phone and being
annoyed by her little brother the film's
directors chris butler and sam fell even
encouraged kendrick to do a surprising
amount of improv and ad living what do
you what are you gonna do ask the
zombies not to eat you johnny depp and
tim burton were making movies together
left and right when he was chosen to
voice victor in burton's stop-motion
film corpse bride despite being one of
the biggest stars in the industry at the
time corp's bride just so happened to be
depp's first voice acting role in a film
having only previously done voice work
as a guest for an episode of king of the
hill a year prior one of the biggest
challenges of doing voice work for
corpse bride was that depp wasn't able
to put together his own character like
he had done for jack sparrow despite
that depp was still able to put his own
spin on victor
where is your chakra
pixar's oscar-winning coco features an
all latino voice cast in order to stay
true to the story's ties to the mexican
holiday dia de los muertos gael garcia
bernal known for his roles in old and
mozart in the jungle jumped at the
opportunity to voice hector as he saw
that the role would give him the
opportunity to be part of something that
his children could watch and enjoy
bernal had always been a fan of pixar
and was truly drawn to the project
because of the world the film builds and
the cultural elements
you're always this nervous before a
performance much of the cast of pixar's
coco is populated by well-known latino
actors but for miguel the film's
protagonist the creative team behind the
film opted to go for young newcomer
anthony gonzalez and i was just so
excited and i just
couldn't believe that i was going to be
in the disney pixar film gonzalez was
extremely interested in the project
especially with the perseverance of the
main character as well as the films
taking place around dia de los muertos a
holiday his family has celebrated since
he was six years old
i don't i don't know
i've never performed before many across
the internet had always dreamed of oscar
isaac playing gomez adams in an atom
family movie so when he was cast as the
voice of the character in the 2019
animated film it was the perfect match
isaac knew he couldn't just use his
regular voice for the role of gomez and
that he really needed to capture the
creepy and kooky spirit of the character
now you're ready since gomez hails from
eastern europe that meant isaac had to
put on an accent in order to accurately
voice him there's definitely something
that's a little bit arch and theatrical
and presentational about him one of the
most well-known spooky themed animated
franchises out there is of course
scooby-doo the team behind the 2020
animated flicks scoob brought on some
a-list talent to voice the iconic
characters including zac efron as fred
the head of the mystery solving monster
stomping mystery inc one of the reasons
why ephron was so attracted to scoob was
director tony cervone's passion for
scooby-doo which encouraged efron to
channel his inner fred the mystery
machine needs a fresh coat of
everything
catherine o'hara is known for her iconic
roles such as moira in shit's creek and
mrs mcallister in home alone but you may
not have realized that she was also the
voice of sally in the holiday classic
the nightmare before christmas o'hara
described the experience as completely
different than anything she has ever
done in her career my dialogue was
patchwork together too with bits of
sentences constructed into sally speak
[Music]
[Applause]
frankenweenie was tim burton's return to
the world of stop motion animation and
he was able to bring some of his
frequent collaborators with him winona
ryder was one of them who worked with
barton on films like beetlejuice and
edward scissorhands but you may know her
best from her role as joyce byers on
stranger things in frankenweenie ryder
voiced elsa van helsing the next door
neighbor and classmate of victor
frankenstein who in one particular scene
sings ryder actually got to work with
legendary composer danny elfman one on
one when recording her singing actually
work with him like directly just me and
him
was very exciting
years after the release of monsters inc
billy crystal reprised his role of mike
wazowski in the prequel monsters
university crystal has had an
illustrious career but out of all the
characters he has played crystal claims
that the short one-eyed monster is his
favorite character he's ever played
crystal loves the honesty and courage of
the character which made him jump at the
chance to play him again this is gonna
be harder than i
charlize theron is one of the most
popular actresses around the world and
her distinctive style and voice made her
the perfect fit as the addams family
matriarch morticia theron expressed her
admiration for the portrayal of morticia
in previous incarnations of the adams
family and described her as a stoic
loving and protective mother and wife
theron felt she didn't want to take away
what made morticia so special which led
her to embrace everything that made her
so popular in the first place
monsters vs aliens was actually rhys
witherspoon's first ever animated film
which presented the oscar winner with
some challenges with her spoon was
unsure how she was supposed to act in
the film whether she was supposed to be
silly and hamming it up or serious but
she was able to get the hang of it soon
enough oh my god is really funny the
book of life was a surprise hit when it
hit theaters in the fall of 2014 with
channing tatum voicing joaquin one of
the three main characters alongside
diego luna and zoe zaldana tatum
definitely had a blast recording his
lines for the movie but he was a bit
disappointed that he wasn't able to
record his lines alongside saldana and
luna no more hiding dante
i gotta seize my moment get ready to
cross over to the land of the dead coco
provided us with an incredible story and
breathtaking visuals but it's the voice
actors that brought this film to life
let's take a look at the voices behind
our favorite characters my papa used to
sing me that song
number one
anthony gonzalez was only 12 years old
when he voiced the determined boy miguel
he was no stranger to acting however as
he had parts on criminal minds beyond
borders and fx's the bridge miguel was
the perfect fit for gonzalez as he
resonated on a personal level with the
character me and miguel are both
persevering and we never give up and we
want to do what we love gonzalez's
connection to the characters shined
through in his performance as he proved
why he was the perfect choice for the
part
i i don't know i've never performed
before one of gonzalez's acting
techniques was to run in place in the
recording booth if he had to do a scene
where miguel was breathing heavily it's
that kind of commitment that makes this
next fact all the more impressive when
recording the song remember me for the
touching scene with mama coco gonzalez
was actually crying in the booth yeah we
were crying too did you know that there
are three versions of it tongue in the
movie even though we can't picture
anyone else in the role now gonzalez
actually didn't get the part right away
he first auditioned when he was just 9
years old and was initially hired to do
scratch vocal work which meant he would
be the temporary voice of the character
until the real actor was cast turns out
he was the perfect actor however as two
years later the crew surprised him with
the news that he had gotten the
permanent part they made the right
choice
number two
gael garcia-bernal wished of being in a
pixar film for some time as he and his
two kids would watch pixar movies
together all the time his wish came true
when he was cast as the lovable hector
bernal loved the story and concept of
the film as he was a big fan of how they
portrayed the day of the dead
celebration they took small aspects of
different regions of mexico with a very
personal point of view around the
celebration even though hector is a
talented songwriter and singer in the
movie bernal wasn't too keen on singing
for the film they told me like
i mean you're okay singing and i was
like no well actually i'm very nervous
about it regardless of his own
trepidations bernal nailed the character
and even received high praise from his
co-star benjamin bratt his presence in
the film lends it true authenticity
number three
ernesto de la cruz was portrayed
masterfully by benjamin bratt and you my
great-great-grandson were meant to be a
musician his father was a big
inspiration for his performance but not
for any of the jealous murdery parts of
the character i thought a lot about my
own father who was a completely
different person from ernesto de la cruz
but someone who shared a similar animal
magnetism someone who walked into a room
and just commanded attention and just
had swagger and confidence much like his
co-star gael garcia bernal brat was
nervous to sing but stated that he loves
a challenge so he was ready to take on
this daunting task the movie was also
very emotional for brat who felt the
emotional impact even before the
animation was complete i was
surprisingly and deeply moved by what i
saw
number four
jaime camille enjoyed his time playing
miguel's papa and was thrilled to be
part of such a culturally rich film
camille got emotional when watching the
films just like many others but the part
that really hit him hard is when he saw
his name in the end credits because he
realized he would be part of pixar's
prestigious catalog forever it was very
special and very touching for me all
that crying however made him have to
explain to his kids why he was so
emotional crying with them is like daddy
are you sad i'm like no i'm crying out
of happiness so explaining to them is
kind of awkward
number five
the sweet and adorable mama coco was
voiced by the equally sweet and adorable
anna ofelia morgia papa was a musician
the mexican actress was 83 years old at
the time of recording her lines proving
that she is still a talented actress at
that age her career leading up to coco
is a prestigious one as she holds the
record for most nominations for best
actress for the ariel awards an award
that recognizes the best in mexican
cinema she also holds the record for
most wins for best supporting actress
for the aerial awards with such an
impressive career it's no wonder she was
chosen to voice mama coco we definitely
remembered her it's okay i'm
here who are you
number six
renee victor played miguel's music
hating abuelita she stated she loves
doing voice work because it only focuses
on the voice and not looks which meant
she could show up to the studio wearing
anything she liked a microphone doesn't
care what you look like she cited
director lee unkrich as a big help as he
guided victor through the voice acting
process so i related more to my mother
than to
uh both of my grandmothers because her
mom had a strong and energetic nature
just like the character her grandmothers
not so much no
music music
number seven
alana ubak knew she had to bring her a
game to play mama imelda after she saw
how detail-oriented and careful the
creators were towards the film she
didn't know much about the movie when
she auditioned and initially thought the
scene it says here no one put up your
photo my family always always puts my
photo on your friend was taking place at
a dmv ubach based her performance on her
aunt and was glad she got the
opportunity to bring her aunt's
personality to life i never forgot the
timber of her voice and her inflections
it meant so much to me even though i was
three and four years old i never forgot
that accent ubak was a huge fan of the
movie's look and feel the music the look
of it it's it's just a bowl of candy
number eight
edward james almost brought great
emotional depth to the character of
chicharron just as other cast members
stated almost reiterated how incredibly
respectful the pixar team was of the
material and he felt privileged and
honored when they offered him the role
almost was never given the story or a
full script so he knew very little about
the movie until he watched it two years
later so you can probably imagine what
happened when he watched the film
number nine
natalia cordova buckley is no stranger
to the screen but this was her first
time voice acting starring in a pixar
movie is a pretty great first experience
just like her co-stars buckley was given
very limited information about the movie
and didn't have a picture of her
character to reference for her
performance however she did know the
real life frida kahlo very well and you
could say it was fate that she got to
play her buckley was bullied when she
was a kid for her lower raspier voice
and she was discouraged from speaking up
about it that was until her father
introduced her to frida kahlo which
helped her significantly she really
helped me strengthen my own voice and
find find the power within my voice we
think kalo would be proud of how buckley
portrayed her
number 10
celene luna provided her voice for tia
rosita bringing an energy to the role
that fit perfectly luna is a little
person and being cast as tia was a big
deal for her being part of coco is still
very emotional for me it validated my
20-year struggle and sacrifice as a
marginalized artist within the
entertainment industry and society as a
whole luna was able to play rosita so
well because she based her performance
off of several older women in her family
who also had nervous personalities just
like rosita and luna did an amazing job
molly needed you you're my favorite
deputy this is just one of the many
iconic lines brought to life by the
actors behind our favorite toys let's
take a look at the voices that created
these characters any other toy would
give up his moving parts just to be you
chris evans was tapped to fill the role
of buzz lightyear for the 2022 film
light year following up tim allen's
iconic role is a big task but evan seems
up to the challenge he expressed his
appreciation on twitter i can't believe
that i get to be a part of the pixar
family and work with these truly
brilliant artists director agnes mclean
said chris evans was his first and only
choice and that evans understood the
material and the character to infinity
and
there is no toy story character more
iconic than woody it was tom hanks first
voice acting gig who thrived in the role
we all knew operation playtime was a
long shot he actually recorded two
versions of the first movie as the
creators didn't like the first script so
they rewrote it and re-recorded it again
hanks explained that the recording
sessions could be stressful on his voice
and body i have driven home after a four
or five hour sometimes six hour
recording session and my diaphragm just
it hurts it aches in order to record the
more emotional scenes hanks had to
either close his eyes or turn his back
to the people in the room
tim allen's buzz lightyear voice is
easily recognizable but it's apparently
also scary as he once scared a child in
an elevator by using the voice buzz
lightyear mission log the local sheriff
and i seem to be at a huge refueling
station of some sort scaring kids aside
alan has given his all into the
character speaking on toy story 4 allen
said he got emotional watching the film
it brought up some of my own personal
stuff about loss change moving on it's
heartwarming don't worry in just a few
hours you'll be sitting around a
campfire with andy making delicious hot
schmoes the cowgirl jessie introduced in
toy story 2 was joan cusack's first
voice acting role
she stated how different it was only
using her voice to act as opposed to
live action as there were no costumes or
makeup to worry about it was kind of
cool to refocus on just your voice and
you know making something crisper clear
kuzak said that playing jessie was about
believing in yourself and what you can
do and we would say she nailed it sweet
mother of abraham lincoln toy story 4
director josh cooley found keanu reeves
when he was listening to soundbites of
potential actors he thought his voice
was perfect for the role of duke kaboom
but didn't think he was going to be able
to get reeves to voice the part however
keanu was excited about the role and
actually stood up on a table to act out
the part during a meeting with the
director duke kaboom canada's greatest
stunt man reeves didn't find the
experience too different from live
action as he said it's the same concept
of finding the right voice and tone of a
character hold on one more
oh yeah wallace sean had a great time
voicing rex for all four toy story
movies what if andy gets another
dinosaur a mean one he never lost touch
with the character even after playing
him for 24 years no matter how much time
has passed when it comes time to do it
again that dinosaur still seems to be in
me i don't have to warm up he magically
leaps into me he loves knowing that his
character can give people joy and stated
that sometimes kids recognize his voice
in public
the late comedian don rickles portrayed
mr potato head in the first three toy
story films hey look i'm picasso he was
a little hesitant to take the part at
first as he had never done voice over
work for an animated character before
luckily he changed his mind and gave mr
potato head the unique voice we know
rickles passed away before toy story 4.
but they used old recordings of his to
bring the character to life one more
time his daughter stated he would be
proud as he always said keep my name
alive let them know who i am you're not
a toy you're an accessory you're a press
with legs
right alongside mr potato head is his
wife mrs potato head voiced by the
lovely estelle harris oh you found it
this was not her first voice acting role
but it was one of her favorites as she
had a great time voicing the character
someplace dark
and dusty she described how it's a bit
difficult to know what you're recording
as they only gave her a couple pages at
a time without much context she was
skeptical about one recording in
particular where she had to make
ninja-like noises but loved it after
seeing it in the movie
[Music]
toy story 2 introduced the character of
al an avid toy collector portrayed by
wayne knight i got a pack let's see
wallet keys tickets it wasn't knight's
first time doing voice work for disney
as he had previously voiced demetrius in
hercules and tantor in tarzan knight
compared voice work to other types of
acting doing animation is interesting in
the sense that you put all your emotions
through your voice it's over the top in
a way that you don't do on stage or film
hopefully knight never had to drive all
the way to work on a saturday to voice
the toy collector
toy story 2 director john lasseter was a
big fan of kelsey grammer's portrayal of
the prospector kelsey's comic timing is
beautiful his acting it's just fantastic
grammar joked that he didn't know his
character's nickname was stinky p and
that it destroyed his career turn me
around bullseye
so i can see
ducky was a new character introduced in
toy story 4. keegan michael key voiced
the plush and had a great time voicing
the role alongside his longtime friend
jordan peele the comedic duo didn't miss
a beat and would improvise songs during
their recordings which made it into the
movie
[Music]
director josh cooley said working with
key was one of the highlights of his
pixar career cheat the system and get
with the kid yeah we know john
ratzenberger is well known at pixar and
his voice is even more well known by the
public as he has provided his voice for
every single pixar movie his first role
however was as ham in toy story even
with his incredible resume ratzenberger
took very little credit for the pixar
characters he has voiced over the years
as he said pixar is doing all the heavy
lifting all you really do is listen to
what they tell you very simple well get
ready for porcha lotso was the purple
bear villain in toy story three
portrayed masterfully by ned beatty
first thing you got to know about me is
i'm a hugger director lee unkrich wanted
someone who could be both comedic and
dramatic which beatty has done both in
previous roles so he was the perfect
choice when coming up with the tone and
demeanor for lotso baby stated unkrich
knew exactly what he wanted and it was
just a matter of finding the right
dialect for the bear welcome to
sunnyside folks the late jim varney
voiced slinky dog in both toy story 1
and 2 which was his first voice over
role as an animated character in his
lifetime he only voiced three animated
characters including this one he
provided his unique raspy voice to bring
slinky to life i knew you'd come back
woody forkey is one of the latest
additions to the toy story crew he's
voiced by tony hale an experienced voice
actor with plenty of animated character
roles under his belt with that said hill
stated he was nervous to be joining such
a beloved franchise so late in the game
but the cast and fans welcomed him with
open arms he played forkey as if he was
a child new to the world without an
understanding of how anything works and
we would say his portrayal was spot on i
am not a toy i'm a spork we love the toy
story films and the voices behind our
favorite characters which toy story
character is your favorite